CHRIS CARTLAND: Welcome to
Google+ Developers Live.
My name is Chris Cartland.
And I'm a developer programs
engineer working on the
Google+ platform.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And I'm
Yaniv Yaakubovich.
I'm a product manager in
the Google+ platform.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Thanks for
joining us this week.
Today we're going to talk about
verifying tokens that
you receive from your client
apps on your server.
So first we're going to talk
about when you need to do
this, when it's important.
We're going to talk about why
and the kind of things you
want to avoid in your app.
And we're also going to
tell you how to do it.
And we're going to look at
some code that we have on
GitHub to actually show you
how to get this done.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And while
we're doing this broadcast,
you can comment and questions
for us either on our Google+
or channel on YouTube,
wherever you're
watching this video.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, and we'll
be sure to get those
questions at the end.
So first of all, we
have to talk about
what we're doing here.
We're talking about requests
coming from your client to
your server.
So if we look on my screen here,
we can see that we're
going to make requests.
And there's two things
that you can do.
One is that you could send
an authorization code.
And we cover that in all
of our Quick Starts.
So you can check those out at
developers.google.com/plus.
Look for the Quick Starts.
Pick your favorite language.
And that's one way to establish
an authenticated
connection with your client
and your server.
Today we're going to talk about
a different way to do
this, and that is by sending
either an ID token or an
access token to your server.
The code for this is available
on GitHub.com/googleplus for
either the Quick Starts or for
the samples that tell you how
to verify the tokens.
So first a little background.
What are these two different
types of tokens that we're
going to be talking
about today?
The first is an ID token.
And an ID token contains
information about the user and
who they are.
And it's also cryptographically
signed by
Google so that you can verify
that this is a real token.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And we'll
show you later in the code how
we can verify that it's
a Google token
and not other token.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Exactly.
An access token is a bearer
token that can be used to make
API calls to Google.
And you need to make sure that
you verify those every time
your server receives
them as well.
If you are going to decide which
one of these to use,
remember that an ID token is a
way to identify who a user is
very quickly.
And an access token is required
if you need to then
make further requests
to Google's APIs.
So depending on what you want to
do, if you want to be fast
and just identify the user,
use an ID token.
If you want to make API calls
to Google, you should use an
access token.
And all of this, I'll say this
again, you should use the one
time code flow instead
of doing this first.
It's preferred because it's more
secure, because that code
can't be intercepted.
And it also gives you a little
more power, which you can read
about in our documentation.
So you should try to
use the code flow.
You also want to make sure that,
if possible, you should
authenticate a session so you
can make multiple requests.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: In cases that
you don't have a session,
then the solution that
we are presenting
today will be relevant.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Exactly.
So if you are not able to
establish multiple requests in
one session, then you need to
authenticate all requests.
And to do that you can send,
say, the ID token or the
access token to do that.
If you don't have the
authorization code, then you
have no choice but to use
something like sending the
access token to your server in
order to make the request.
And right now, iOS doesn't
have that.
So you'll need to do that.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And we're
looking into solving it in the
near future.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So we want to
show you briefly how to get
these tokens before we talk
about how to verify them.
So on Android, if you want to
get an ID token you can use
Google AuthUtil.
Use this syntax that I
have on the screen.
And make sure that you do this
in an AsyncTask so that it
doesn't block anything
in the app.
And you'll get a string back
that you can then send
securely to your server.
If you want to get an access
token, you do a
very similar thing.
But you change the third
argument to match the syntax
that I have on the
screen here.
And these are just the way that
your client will get the
token to send to your server.
On the web, you do it a little
bit differently.
You start with the call
back from the sign in.
And in your auth result, you can
get both the ID token and
the access token as strings.
And you can send those to
your server as well.
Web is most likely the one
where you're going to
use the code flow.
So if you can help
it, you probably
won't have to do this.
On iOS, you get an access token
in the auth object from
finished with auth.
And you can send that string
to your server.
This is the place you're most
likely to use these methods
because we don't have an
authorization code available.
So why do we want to
verify this tokens?
Why is that important?
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Well, there
are two main cases.
One is when you have
an invalid token.
Either the token expired or the
token is from an app that
is not really your app, or when
you have a bad client.
You want to give an
example for that?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so a bad
client would be like if you
have an attacker who gets users
the sign in to their app
and gets some to hit
the consent screen.
That person, that developer,
could send tokens and make
requests to your server.
And they would be real tokens.
They would actually be
issued by Google.
So just check to make sure
that they are real.
And then check to see what user
was attached to that.
You may give an attacker access
to a user's information
even though that user never
signed into your app.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And that's
the reason that you're
verifying that this token will
run for your app based
on your client ID.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Absolutely.
So it's very critical that you
check to make sure that this
token for your app and not just
someone's app on the internet.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Right.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So how
we're going to do
this is do two things.
First, we check to make
sure that the
tokens are made by Google.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And then you
want to check that these
tokens are meant for your
app using the client ID.
And you can set the client
ID and verify
it in the dev console.
CHRIS CARTLAND: So yeah, in the
Google API console when
you set up your project you will
create a web client ID.
And so depending on what type
of token you're sending, you
have to make sure that the
client ID for that token is
the one that you're checking
on the server.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And you're
most likely to have a
different client ID for
each of your apps.
So for your Android app, you'll
have one client ID,
another one for your desktop
app, and another for your iOS.
CHRIS CARTLAND: That's
correct.
So depending on which token
you have, you have to do
slightly different steps.
Let's start with the ID token.
First, we're going to
check to make sure
it's issued by Google.
So how do we do that?
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Well, you
check the signature using the
Google API.
And we'll show you the
code that does it.
And then you do the same
for access token.
You call the token in for API.
The second step would be to
check your client ID.
You compare the client ID with
the token that you just read
on the ID token.
And again, you do it with the
token API response and the
token info response to verify
the access token.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Exactly.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Step number
one, number two are essential
to verify the tokens.
And step three is only the stuff
that we're using for
this example.
You can use any other step that
is relevant for your app
at this stage.
And we'll show you just
one of those examples.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Exactly.
So we're going to show you the
first two steps to make sure
that it's verified.
And then we're going to also
get the user ID, because
that's a useful thing for
your client to know.
Once you've authenticated with
your server, now your client
will know who the user is.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Now do you
want to repeat, for those who
didn't hear us, when do you
need to check ID token and
access token?
Do you need to do it every time
that you call the API or
per session?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, yeah.
So the first time you make a
request from that client, you
always need to check
it in some way.
So if you've done an
authorization code, that is
your first connection to
authenticate between your
client and your server.
You may not have that.
So again, the first time you
send an ID token or access
token, you need to do that.
Every time that you get a new ID
token or access token from
your client that you can't
trust, you need to make sure
that you verify it.
If you have the option, though,
you should try and
authenticate a session, though,
so you don't have to
do this check for every request
that comes in from
your clients.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: So ideally
you'll do this check once you
start a session.
As long as the session is alive,
you'll assume that
these steps, these tokens are
already valid, and you
continue without checking
it again.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, and if the
session is already valid
you probably don't even need
to send the ID token or the
access token again, because
you already know who is
on the other end.
So great, let's look
at some code.
We have samples available
in five languages.
We're going to look at GitHub
before PHP today.
But you can pick your favorite
language and see how it works.
The logic is the same
in all of them.
So you'll even get the same
responses in your client apps.
So first on Google+, we have
this G+ verify token PHP.
It looks very similar
to our Quick Starts.
So if you haven't done that yet,
you should do the Quick
Start first, because we think
that's the one that you're
going to need to use.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: They're
fairly simple, very easy to
integrate, very easy to follow
the examples that we have over
there with regard to allow
you to spend less time on
developing for our platform and
most time on developing
your actual app.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Exactly.
So the relevant piece for
verifying tokens in this
sample is in verify.php.
The files are named similarly
in the other
languages as well.
Great.
So this is very similar, again,
to the Quick Starts.
The main difference is that we
have an endpoint slash verify.
So the client, which when we run
the sample is the web app,
is going to send an ID token and
an access token to local
host slash verify.
And we're going to make sure
that if there's an access
token, we're going to make
sure that it's real.
And we're going to make sure
it's for your app.
And then we're going to
look at the access--
sorry, I said the wrong one.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: You
said the access.
We'll show you how you do the
access token and the ID token.
CHRIS CARTLAND: And it doesn't
matter which one is which.
So we'll start by pulling the ID
token and the access token
into strings in PHP.
Everything that we do in the
sample is going to be returned
in this array.
So it's going to say token
status is going to have
information about what
tokens it received.
To start, we're going to have
the ID token status.
And we're going to create an
empty array to hold that
information.
So we'll check the ID token
first, which we're only going
to do if the client
sent an ID token.
The real easy thing about
verifying the ID token in PHP
is that the client library
does this for you.
So we just call client, verify
ID token with the string,
which is the ID token.
And we pass the client
ID as well.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And the
client library should be
available for you anytime
that you use our apps.
If you start following the steps
on the Quick Start, or
even the steps that we have in
GitHub, in one of them you'll
download the client library.
And you'll have it
for your server.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
It's very straightforward.
All of the complicated stuff
we've been talking about is
taken care of in this
function call.
And what you get back is a JSON
web token that contains
information about the user.
And we can get the Google+ user
ID from the payload under
the field called sub, which
stands for subscriber.
The rest of the code here just
takes that information and
puts it into the ID status
object, which was going to get
returned in the HTTP request.
If the token is not valid,
we throw an exception.
And we know that either the
token wasn't real or it wasn't
issued for your app.
One thing to keep in mind is
that this client ID needs to
be the client ID that matches
the token that was sent.
So if for some reason you have
multiple tokens that are
registered coming from
different apps
that are still yours--
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Like an
Android app, an iOS app, and
the desktop app, all different
apps that you're the publisher
of all of those.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so if you
have the tokens that have
different client ID registered,
then you may need
to check this multiple times
to find which client ID
matches your app.
And then we would take
this information.
And we're going to return
it in the token
status when we return.
That's great.
That's the ID token.
Let's take a look at the
access token now.
Very similarly, we're going to
create an empty array to hold
the information.
If there is an access token,
then we're going to make a
request to the token info API.
So by itself, the string
doesn't contain any
information.
You have to use it to ask
Google for something.
And the token info API is a very
easy way of finding out
who the token is issued for.
So we make this HTTP
request to Google.
And we read the response back.
If the token is real, which
means it is an access token
issued by Google, then
you will get no
errors in your response.
If you do get an error, then
you know that you have an
invalid access token.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And
here's the place to
handle those errors.
You can either show a message to
the user or simply drop the
message from there to your log
and verify what happened and
continue from there.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yep, exactly.
Once you've verified that the
token is from Google and is
real, you want to make sure that
it's issued to your app.
So we check that client
ID much like we
did with the ID token.
Make sure that you do this step
so that you avoid the
problem where someone else's
app sends their real access
token to your server.
You need to check this,
otherwise you're causing
problems for you
and your users.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Or even the
case that one app that you
developed overrides the other
app, and you do some mistakes.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah, so you
want to make sure that you
expect the right tokens
from each client.
And once you've checked those
two things, you can trust the
access token is valid and
meant for your app.
And in our response, we say
that it was a valid token.
We can get the Google+ user ID
from the token info response,
because every token that is
issued in our OAuth 2.0 code
is issued for a specific user.
And so once we get that back,
we know who the user is.
And they've authenticated
that request.
We're going to say that the
token valid, put that into a
response, and return all that
information in a JSON response.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH:
Pretty simple.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Very good.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH:
How would it look
like in other languages?
CHRIS CARTLAND: It looks
almost the same
in every other language.
So we have the same structure.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Same logic,
just a few tweaks based on
their language, correct?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
You have to create an actual
object in Java.
You have to use different
syntax, obviously, in
different languages.
But the logic and how you
accomplish each of these
things is exactly the same.
And of course, you can
look through the
code to figure out.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: And it's
all in our GitHub?
CHRIS CARTLAND: Everything
that we've
talked about is on GitHub.
So you should try it
out for yourself.
Great.
So thank you for joining us.
Today we talked about
verifying tokens.
We talked about when to do it,
which is when you cannot use
the code flow, or you need to
make requests, many requests,
in a way that you don't have
an established session.
We talked about why you need
to verify these tokens, so
that people who you're expecting
to be authenticated
are making real authenticated
requests.
You also need to make sure that
attackers are not able to
use their tokens to get access
to your users information.
And we talked about
how to do that.
We have all of the information
on GitHub for you to check it
out and try it yourself.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Great.
We'll give you the ability
to offer us questions.
Well, I don't see any questions
right now on YouTube
or G+ event page.
If you have any questions, feel
free to add them to our
event page.
We can take them later
after this broadcast.
CHRIS CARTLAND: Yeah.
And as always, you can try out
our normal documentation for
getting started with
Google+ sign in at
developers.google.com/plus.
You can ask us questions in
our Google+ Developers
community or on Stack Overflow
with the tag Google+.
We're happy to get feedback on
how well these things work for
you, how easy they are, so that
we can continue to make
things better for you.
But I think that that's all
we have free today.
Thank you so much for joining
us today, Yaniv.
And we'd be happy to
have you back.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Great.
Thank you very much.
CHRIS CARTLAND: All right,
thank you, everyone.
Bye.
YANIV YAAKUBOVICH: Bye.